the 1955 suzu light the first car suzuki
ever made
the company had started in 1909 as a
loom manufacturer
by 1936 suzuki moved from shuttling warp
and wool to shuttling people at first on
motorized bicycles and nearly 20 years
later with japan's own version of the
people's car another 20 years later
suzuki first ventured into the german
car market
explains that suzuki debuted on the
german market in 1980 with its lj-80
today it may seem a bit rustic and tight
he describes the transmission as more
adventurous than convenient but that's
all changed now
when suzuki rolled off its first
off-roader in 1970 the brand was only
known in germany as a motorcycle that
swiftly changed with the development of
the top-selling lj model line
whoa here comes the lj the crazy
reasonable fun economical and cutest car
in the world the lj is the cross-country
vehicle for city driving and the city
car for cross-country driving originally
developed for military use the lj hits
germany's roads as an all-wheel drive
multi-purpose car at a sensationally
explains that suzuki entered the german
market with a little all-terrain vehicle
the lj-80
it's 12 and a half thousand deutsche
list price made all-wheel drive
affordable for everyone
soon after came the first mini cars the
alto and the swift
now there's a broad range of mini cars
compacts and all-wheel drive vehicles
the alto was small but still spacious in
1981 with a three-cylinder engine and
some unexpected extras it started
carving out a comfortable market niche
buyers of suzuki's two-seat
micro-convertible cappuccinos had to act
fast only 120 were offered on the german
market starting in 1994.
back in japan the ultralight mini
roadsters had already been a favorite
with young and dynamic fun seekers for
three years
suzuki also proved a trendsetter for
microvans launching their worldwide
automotive exports in 1960 with the
carry its 1.86 metre inside height
enough for a tall man to stand straight
made it a hit with handymen and traits
people of all kinds
says when people think of suzuki
all-wheel drive has a prominent place so
they intend to keep producing vehicles
of this kind for example the im4 concept
car suzuki's just premiered at the
geneva motor show it'll be appearing on
the german market in the foreseeable
future it's another sub-compact sporting
all-wheel drive there's also the new
vitara with intelligent all-wheel drive
there's a type suitable for every
driving situation and suzuki intends to
continue their development
points out that the vitara has little in
common with the lj-80 but that can be a
good thing it's more spacious the
transmission is a dream and the
workmanship is far better and up-to-date
so he sees a bright future for suzuki
especially for its all-wheel drive cars
and vans